e aí é que chova na tudo bom vocês ainda
lembro de mim acho que nem eu faço tempo
e um dia desculpa tá tá am
desculpa mas você também sabendo nós que
são urgentes ou insumo está o caro que é
dono do canal eu faço vídeos aqui tá
a gente sabe que a gente eu fui assistir
os vingadores no cinema gente e seb
macho ser aquele tom é lindo de mato
grosso extinguiu os vingadores o
primeiro eu já gostei quando fui
assistir esse segundo marcelo mesmo pra
vocês como eu fiz questão de tirar a
camisinha que tinha dentro da minha
carteira e joguei fora porque o filme em
3d mach eu queria muito muito
engravidado toomey lindo da bola mas
como é que pode às vezes a vida é
injusta com ele porque o cara bonito
tudo bem vamos seguir ou ser bonito tudo
bem agora o cara limpa único ainda vivo
em poder
acho o filme já começa na pancada areia
loucura loucura total só que só que tem
duas pessoas 2002 inimigos nós né
é o pedro ken é um cara que com ele é
muito rápido mas ele é extremamente
rápidos a copa isso rápido existe
somente duas pessoas rápida nesse mundo
é o seu bote e o outro é o flanelinha o
índice 'flanelinha' a é rap mas entre o
seu carro e os baladeiros o [ __ ] 350
pororoca de 50 centavo esse cara é mais
rápido né esse cara limpa seu carro que
o carro surge é muito macho ele é muito
rápido ele é rápido tipo assim o é um
pouco mais rápido que o filho lhe corte
estava na cidade da luz
eu fico imaginando a mãe desse cara quer
bater nele dentro e eu volte aqui eu não
volte aqui agora nunca não quer vê lo
aí eu fui dizer isso e tem a irmã de
ficar e ela ela mexe com a mente das
pessoas ela mexe com a cabeça das
pessoas para deixar as pessoas vendo
coisas a pessoa fica louca
é como se fosse
a maconha só que mulheres craddock
debutando ela chega oscar e foi assim
a star já que assim o som do filho do
homem caiu o que dá um beijo melo
agradece à loucura sabe quem é e quem
logo no rookie o que fica no quilômetro
60 kurylenko não sendo um jogo que o
machão fica louco louco ponto onde ferro
na cidade múltipla raymond fel decide
que é hora de chamar vera única luta que
pariu [ __ ] vai chamar ver o ranking
eu precisava me diz quem eram gente
verônica é um o buondi festa adquirido
tamanho do huck vai pensar agora vai ser
de igual para igual vai ser o hulk
contra rock and roll que deixa esse robô
igual a boca e o hulk contra esse roubo
é uma luta muito forte é quase igual
para igual é como se você tivesse que
escolher no brasil no play lembra que
quando era jogar futebol agora jogo
valer agora valendo só não vai escolher
o brasil porque é a samsung é a surpresa
desse filme macho a natasha que aquela
mulher lá aquela mulher scarlett a
escala de skate a língua de michelle
linda demais ela só tem um problema
beija mal beija muito mal acho ela e o
hulk se apaixona natasha e hulk se
apaixonou um piloto mas eu não pensei
outra coisa quando estava no meio da rua
e do rio uma menina assim bem baixinha
namorando com um cabo que é tipo o dobro
dela um jogador de vôlei e sim dito com
o jogador de basquete a história a
menina é o cara é uma menina época é
terminar a época em que o pai pensa
assim
será se aguenta eu olhava povo que olhar
para a taxa pensava assim vai entrar aí
é aquela dúvida e centrar a eu pensava
meu deus do céu deus tenha piedade que
já viu que eu já vi gente sobreviver a
um mundo o que agora quer saber ver a
roda não tem quem faça sobreviver à roda
do carro que é a nossa casa dos
vingadores
a outra carro acabou o inverso meu deus
que vamos fazer trás da rua do rock funk
rock machida um negócio desse da filho
da criança eu fico imaginando sei do
huck unir vai nascer a estou tendo
contrações arte do filme contrações acho
que eu contei o menino eu posso ficar
varre sai no meio da manhã
assim na escola esse laço 6 mil não
estava aqui é meio esclarece é meu não
está aqui é meio s 9 é bom é teu pode
ficar até ontem que também pega eu estou
aí mas tenta criar uma inteligência
artificial de proteger o universo em que
dá errado e aí eu estou uma vida própria
e aí quer por várias caravanas olha isso
aí tá muito obrigada a assistir e se vir
até aqui para me ajudar você faz o que
você está no facebook serviu e se postar
no facebook vai firmar com amigos seus
comentários para assistir tac no youtube
clique em gostei me ajuda demais clique
em inscrever se você nunca perdeu os
vídeos do canal ea rede social tudo na
descrição do vídeo levante não pode
deixar de acompanhar meu show de stand
up que eu faço também está aqui o
primeiro na descrição do vídeo a minha
agenda de shows só você olhar pra ficar
esperto e hotel valeu é 2 e quer